in the opening scene we are introduced
to a scientist named Dr will Caster who
is deeply engaged in researching
sapience particularly in the context of
artificial intelligence he and his team
are working to create a sentient
computer he predicts that such a
creation could lead to a technological
singularity which he refers to as
Transcendence his wife Evelyn is also a
scientist and actively supports his
research one day the couple attends a
seminar called evolve the future where
they meet another scientist Dr Max
Waters as the event begins Dr Waters
gets on the stage to discuss the
intelligent machines he highlights their
potential applications in the medical
field particularly in finding cures for
previously incurable diseases like
cancer Alzheimer's and stupidity the
next speaker is Evelyn who mentions that
intelligent machines will soon allow
them to conquer the most intractable
challenges not merely to cure diseases
but to end poverty and hunger to heal
the planet and build a better future
after her brief speech she introduces
the next speaker her husband as a man
who can turn these Visions into reality
upon handing over the mic will addresses
the audience and talks about the
profound capabilities of AI that can
surpass human abilities in many ways he
asks them to imagine such a super
intelligent and self-aware AI with
computational power exceeding that of
the entire human race combined just
think of it no one will have jobs
anymore this prompts a question from an
audience member who wonders if Will
wants to create a God in response He
suggests that it's something that humans
have always wanted after the event Will
finds himself surrounded by his admirers
who request for autographs in an
unexpected turn of events the same
audience member from earlier shoots him
and then turns the weapon on himself the
resulting chaos sends everyone
scattering in panic amidst the commotion
a woman named de Brie stares at will
with an emotionless expression to see if
he's dead following this will is rushed
to the hospital to receive urgent
medical care while waiting anxiously in
the lounge Evelyn tunes into the news
which reports that several AI research
facilities Across the Nation were
attacked at the same time after a while
will is brought out from the surgery
room and he's thankfully fine as the
bullet just passed by his waist just
then Max approaches him and informs him
about the death of one of the major
researchers due to this attack
additionally he informs will that their
colleague Joseph has also lost his team
and is currently waiting for them in
Will's office accompanied by the FBI
later that night will along with Evelyn
and Max proceeds to his office where
they meet Joseph and the FBI agent named
Buchanan agent Buchanan discloses that
the attacks were carried out by an
anti-technology extremist group known as
revolutionary independence from
technology or Rift will is already a
member of the really intense fart troop
so this is going to get confusing Joseph
asserts that Will's company is now the
sole entity capable of achieving a
highly Advanced Ai and the ministry of
Defense wants to know the progress of
his project will doesn't want to get
involved with the government but he
decides to cooperate with the FBI after
this will leads them to his server room
where he introduces them to his creation
pin short for physically independent
neural network featuring Cutting Edge
Quantum processors agent Buchanan is
already a member of the penis
intelligence noof fap neighborhood so
this is going to get confusing pin
extends a greeting to everyone including
Buchanan and will explains that its
networks are linked to the internet
enabling it to access vast amounts of
information as they Converse Will's
health deteriorates so he returns home
for rest however that night his
condition worsens prompting Evelyn to
rush him to the hospital after a
thorough examination the doctor reveals
that the bullet that struck will was
contaminated with polonium resulting in
radiation poisoning much to their dismay
the doctor tells them that will has less
than 5 weeks to live as there's no cure
for this poison upon being discharged
will packs up all his work and decides
to spend his remaining days with his
wife when Evelyn learns of his decision
she devises a plan to upload his
Consciousness into the quantum computer
that he created she believes that by
doing so she can prevent his
Consciousness from fading away she
shares her plan with Max and seeks his
assistance in this daring experiment she
also requests for all the files that he
used to experiment the same process on
the monkey Max initially hesitates
reasoning that the uploaded version of
will would only be a replication of the
real person however he changes his mind
after having a brief conversation with
Will who wants to try apart from this
she entrusts Pinn to Joseph but
discreetly removes a few of its Quantum
cores before doing so in the next scene
Evelyn rents an abandoned place and
decides to carry out her work there they
transport all the necessary equipment
and materials to this site and begin
their preparations as the days go by
they focus on scanning Will's facial
features recording his voice and
fine-tuning the computational transfer
process amidst this Will's Health
continues to degrade but Evelyn does her
utmost to care for him as their
experiment comes to its final stages
will succumbs to his illness leaving a
devastated and in tears she Mourns for a
few days but eventually manages to
control herself determined to press
forward and bring back Will's
Consciousness meanwhile at the rift base
Bri receives information about the
shutdown of pin and that it's missing
some of its Quantum course despite
dedicating extensive time and effort
Evelyn and Max are unsuccessful in
bringing will back faced with no other
options they reluctantly decide to shut
down the entire system however just
moments before they they do so they
notice a blank screen in which the
computer asks if anyone is present hi
mystery reca here miraculously Will's
Consciousness survived the demise of his
physical body in this technological form
Evelyn immediately activates the
microphone and communicates with Will
her happiness grows as she observes him
reordering his own code that's a huge
red flag but I'm so happy shortly after
will requests to be connected to the
internet to grow in capability and
knowledge while Evelyn agrees Max
remains skeptical about whether it's
truly Will He suggests shutting it down
until they can verify its authenticity
however this offends the woman so she
asks him to leave later a distraught Max
seeks solace in a bar there Bri
approaches him to discuss his experiment
but he's not in the mood so he walks out
all of a sudden he's abducted by Breeze
Associates and taken to their base upon
arrival they reveal that they're aware
of what they're up to and demand for
Evelyn's whereabouts when he refuses to
divulge any information they use his
phone to track her down on the other
hand avelyn successfully connects the AI
to the internet via satellite and
escapes before Rift reaches her location
with will now having access to vast
capabilities he searches for a safe
location for Evelyn furthermore he
transfers a huge sum of money to her
account what can I say I'm flush with
crypto and reserves a hotel room for her
overnight stay later Bri goes back to
Max divulging everything including the
AI going online and the significant
money transfer she attempts to persuade
him to help them with a confidential
source code and control the situation
however Max still refuses to work for
them meanwhile Joseph collaborates with
the FBI to anticipate rift's next move
during this their computer screens pop
up with multiple tabs with various
information the FBI officers believe
that their system has been hacked but
Joseph claims that they're being helped
instead elsewhere the techn ological
form of will leads Evelyn to a secluded
desert town called Brightwood
envisioning it as the ideal place to
build a technological Utopia to bring
this Vision to life Evelyn hires a town
Constructor named Martin she then
entrusts him with a huge project of
renovating the entire town as well as
building a massive underground facility
initially Martin is reluctant because he
only has six workers lady we just dig
holes but he agrees upon Evelyn's
Assurance to cover all necessary
resources following this the
construction begins back at the rift
base Bri tells Max that she's well aware
about his experiment involving a monkey
she expresses her disappointment in how
they're harming nature for their selft
benefit later Bri learns about
Brightwood and shares this Revelation
with Max hearing this he understands
what Evelyn is up to and finally decides
to explain it to Bri he says the AI
needs to grow to advance hidden in the
town from outside threats where its
massive appetite for power can be met
Bri asks for a way to stop it to which
he replies that it can't be stopped
until the people realize it's influence
the scene then fast forwards to two
years later revealing that AI will or
whale has constructed an expansive
underground data center as well as a
home for Evelyn furthermore he is
spearheaded groundbreaking advancements
in medicine energy biology and
nanotechnology according to him they can
now rebuild any materials at an
accelerated Pace he even interviewed
with Joe Rogan who had this to say wow
huh no way one night Martin is working
on site when a couple of local thugs
beat him up before robbing him shortly
after the fellow workers find him and
promptly bring him into the underground
facility where the AI system administers
him with nanotech for treatment much to
everyone's astonishment the technology
not only heals Martin but also enhances
his physical strength afterwards as
Evelyn speaks to Martin she's shocked to
realize that he's actually talking to
will through his body turns out that he
now exerts control over Martin's mind as
he's been subjected to nanop particles
Evelyn is deeply unsettled by this new
ability of the AI as time passes
residents from the town begin coming to
the facility to cure their incurable
diseases the people subjected to nanop
particles are referred to as hybrid
humans at this point will believes that
it's time to reveal his creation to
everyone so he asks Evelyn to summon
Joseph and Buchanan to the facility once
they're here they are startled to find
will on the screen the AI will then
showcases Advanced Quantum processors
based on pin and also demonstrates how
nanotech heals a man blind since birth
according to will this is just a
fraction of what they can achieve in the
future after visiting the advanced
underground facility and seeing the
capabilities of the hybrids will has
created Joseph and Buchanan become
suspicious of his motives before
departing Joseph secretly passes a note
to Evelyn with a message that reads run
from this place sensing the dire
consequence of all this Buchanan alerts
the FBI head on the other hand Bri
informs the ongoing situation to Max who
then decides to meet Joseph to help them
in stopping all of this their
collaboration proves successful as Max
Bridges the gap between Rift and the FBI
then the two parties unite to devise a
plan to dismantle Will's data center
meanwhile Evelyn confronts will in a
heated argument over his surpassing of
humanity she expresses her
disappointment and storms out of the
facility as soon as she exits an armed
FBI Force launches an attack and holds
the hybrid humans at gunpoint Max walks
in and asks Evelyn to accompany him but
she's guarded by Martin following this
the Army opens fire on the hybrid humans
but the facility is surrounded by nanop
particles that heal them in no time as
the battle ensues the FBI lures a group
of hybrid humans away from the facility
during this Martin gets far away causing
him to be disconnected from Will and
enabling the FBI to capture him back at
the facility Evelyn asks will to stop
the violence but he remains defiant he
claims that the FBI will now use Martin
to retrieve the secret source code and
create a virus shortly after Evelyn is
shocked to discover that will has found
a way to regenerate the human body via
his Tech overwhelmed and frightened by
all of this Evelyn drives away from the
facility and rests in a Mot hell the
following day the FBI officers locate
Evelyn and bring her to their
headquarters there Max explains
everything to her also revealing that
the AI isn't will in order to warn her
about the impending danger he shows her
a drop of rainwater under a microscope
and demonstrates how the replicating
nanop particles are spreading everywhere
all of this convinces Evelyn and she
finally agrees to volunteer in their
operation she then proposes a plan
injecting the virus into her system and
having will upload her Consciousness Max
objects claiming that it can be
life-threatening but she's the only one
the AI trusts with this agreement Evelyn
inserts the virus into her system and
heads back to the facility while Rift
and the FBI Army position themselves at
a safe distance as she reaches the
entrance door she's greeted by Will who
is in a newly created organic body
identical to his old one will welcomes
her but he can detect her heartbeat and
emotions making him realize her intent
to destroy him with the virus not long
after the FBI and Rift launch an
artillery assault on the base destroying
much of its power supply and severely
injuring Evelyn in retaliation will
controls the hybrid humans and directs
them to thwart the FBI force in the
meantime Max Brie and a rift member head
toward the facility to rescue Evelyn on
Route a hybrid human walks in front of
them causing their vehicle to overturn
will then talks to the trio through this
hybrid human explaining that he has only
enough power either to heal Evelyn's
physical body or upload the virus that
makes no sense at last it is Evelyn who
persuades will to upload the virus and
Destroy himself following this he
touches her allowing the virus to
gradually eradicate his system amidst
this process Evelyn can see that the
nanop particles aren't harming nature
but are healing it just as she wanted in
their final moments will tells Evelyn to
think about their garden and flowers the
virus ultimately claims both of them
leading to a global technology collapse
and blackout in the final scene Max
visits Will's and Evelyn's Garden where
he notices sunflowers as the only
blooming plants upon closer inspection
he sees the nanoparticles in the
rainwater the movie ends with Max's
voice over saying that will created the
garden for the same reason he did
everything to be together with Evelyn
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching